let's finish off quadrilaterals it I
should take Carla quadrilateral areas
you know the last one because after this
we're going to be much use of different
kinds of shapes is where we'll show you
them it was too I wasn't very civil to
each other so before we get to them
let's just remember right um we learnt a
series of basic shapes very very simple
shapes okay the start of weird the
rectangle rectangle and what's the area
of a rectangle okay x breath yeah very
good let's get a heads up for this one's
okay we thought about the area of a
triangle right which is heads up is
going to be enough yeah good we usually
write it down for medical actually I was
going to say a big order but this is
what happen so anyhow this is no half
base times height tends to be the way to
the trizol it's worth noting right then
you've got bread to cross here hell up
here literally a triangle is just half a
rectangle that's why it's hot okay other
kinds of shapes we looked at there's
that special kind of rectangle where all
of the sides are the same which of
course is that square very good and if
each side is like s4 side okay so I tied
tight side then we would say the area is
s squared get it because it's a square
okay now again coming off the rectangle
I hope you remember by the way right
well we did that whole big you know
whiteboard full diagram of how all of
the shapes fit together right we have
all those arrows showing the
relationships we shouldn't be surprised
that there are all these relationships
between not just the answer the shapes
but the formulas that give us their
areas right so after this guy we looked
at the parallelogram right and what's
the area of a parallelogram yep
okay so be careful with this one it is
kind of length Thanks breath but if you
call this one here the breath right then
you can't just use this this leaning
over side for the legs right you need
something else yeah Shane breath how
broad something is like broad-shouldered
so now you can just you can use your
bread broad Lord breathy sit down well
yeah it depends to Adam yeah yes that's
exactly right and the way I remember
this remember we eventually last time is
it's got a triangle it literally looks
like at H for height okay so you've got
your your height there and area is base
times height okay or bread times height
if you like okay now from there from all
of these we moved on to kompis suit
areas to remember that compass it shapes
what's a composite shape who remembers
hand up he remembers our a definition or
a way to explain what a corpus of shape
is somebody has a said anything yet
today yeah if you know your shot
fantastic figures right that I've made
up off that's what opposite means other
kinds of shapes like these kinds of guys
okay now the reason why this is really
helpful is because when we looked at
last lesson we did the trapezium that
something like this okay and the reason
why I was helpful to go from copies of
shapes to this is because we can slice
this thing up I had that piece of paper
out and I said okay let's divide up this
shape I'm going to start in this corner
and I'm going to go to your halfway down
this side it's gonna look like
okay and you can see what I've got up
here here is I'll just put it in blue
for you I have a triangle right you see
that I want to do is I'm going to take
that triangle and I literally I
literally rotated it around this point
here okay and what I ended up with is
something ideas okay it's the same
triangle so it's the same area I've just
rearranged it a little bit and what's
great about it is now I can see by
thinking of the trapezium as a composite
shape this trapezium is exactly the same
as this triangle that's the triangle
restored okay you've got one hell else I
hear another parallel side here this is
our height again you've got that H
looking thing from the right angle and
so that's why the area of this thing
it's just like the area of this thing
it's just that the base is how long how
long's that base 25 it's going to be in
this case 25 a plus B right a plus B and
that's where we got our area of a
trapezium for a change